Me,
my heart aches and a drowsy,
numbness,
pains,
my sense of him like I had drunk and
emptied some dough opiate to the drains
in one minute past leafy words had some
is that through envy of buy happy lot,
but being too happy and nine happiness
the Dow light when you're dry out of the
trees in some melodious plot of beach in
green and shadows.
Number list,
singer stuff.
Summer in full throated ease.
Oh,
for drafting vintage that has been
cooled along age and the deep delving.
Earth tasting of flora in the country.
Green,
dense and prevent style,
song and sunburnt mirth.
Oh,
for beaker,
full of the warm south,
full of the truth,
the blush,
full hypocretin with beaded bubbles
winking at the brim and purples stated
mouth that I might drink and leave the
world unseen and with the fade away into
the forest and fade faraway dissolve and
quite forget what thou among the leads
has never known the weariness,
the fever,
and the fret here where men sit and hear
each other grown.
We're posey shakes.
A few sad last gray hair is where youth
grows pale and specter thin and dyes
were but to think is to be full of
sorrows and let denied despairs where
beauty cannot keep her less resize or
new love pine at them beyond tomorrow,
away away for I will fly with the nut
charioted by back,
sent his parts,
but on the swings of Posey,
though the Dole brain perplexes and
retards already with the tender is the
night and happily the queen moon is on
her throne,
clustered around by all her story phase,
but here there is no light.
Say what?
From heaviness,
with the reasons blown through virtuous
glooms and winding Masi ways,
I cannot see what flowers are at my
feet,
nor what soft incense hangs upon the
bowels,
but in embalmment darkness,
guests each suite where with the
seasonable month endows the grass,
the thicket,
and the fruit tree,
wild white Hawthorne in the pastoral
Eggland time,
fast fading,
Violet's covered up and leaves and mid
maze.
Eldest child,
the coming must gross full of do we wind
murmurs,
haunt flies on summaries.
Darkling.
I listened for many a time.
I have been half in love with easeful
death
called him names and many amused Ryan to
take into the air.
My quiet breath now more than ever.
Seems it rich today to cease upon the
midnight with no pain.
Well that are pouring for thei soul
abroad in such an ecstasy still would've
stopped soon and I had ears in vain to
high requiem become a site that was not
born for death.
Mortal Bird,
no hung regenerations tread the down.
The same voice I hear this passing night
was heard in ancient days by emperor and
clown,
perhaps the self same song that found a
path through the sad part of ruth when
sick for home.
She stood in tears amid the alien core
in the same that oftentimes have charmed
magic casements opening on the foam of
perilous seas in fairy lands for Lauren.
Very word.
He's like a bell to tow me back from the
to my soul self.
Do you
the fancy cannot cheat so well as she
has failed to do deceiving.
Uh,
do you?
do you buy plaintiff?
Anthem fades past the near meadows,
over the stream,
up the hillside.
And now is buried deep in the next
valley glade.
Was it division
or a waking dream?
Flood.
Is that music?
Do I wake or sleep.